I think it's time we blew this scene get
everybody in this stuff together okay
three two one let's jam oh I wish I
could have actually kicked in the music
after that without you know risking
getting this whole thing flag under
somebody else's copyright but again so
there we go alright so yeah a few days
ago and I would have jumped on this
sooner but I didn't want to rearrange
the stuff I'd already planned for the
rest of last week it was announced that
Netflix is moving forward with a
live-action adaptation of Cowboy Bebop
I shouldn't have to talk too much about
my feelings about live-action
adaptations of animated works in general
because you know my thoughts that I gave
about Disney remaking its animated films
as live-action applies here as well so
you know you can look to that to see how
I feel it denigrates animation as an art
form in general because it reinforces
the idea that live-action is the
quote-unquote real version but beyond
that it's very odd to me that Netflix
especially is jumping I'm not given how
not very well received the Netflix Death
Note movie was now to be fair I haven't
seen death now and I have no idea how
good it was or wasn't or how good of a
representation of the original work it
was or wasn't people didn't really
didn't seem to like it though of course
whether or not people liked it and
whether or not it actually got the
returns that the that Netflix wanted r2
completed in four conversations and
unfortunately talking about these sorts
of things with Netflix we are hamstrung
about the fact that Netflix doesn't put
its viewing numbers out when it comes to
something like say the Transformers
movies we can go boy a lot of people
seem to really not like this but then we
can look at the box-office and go that's
why they keep making it so we can
I could presume that Death Note pulled
in decent viewing numbers despite the
reception but I also don't know
so after at the very least assumed that
the bad fan reception was not reflected
in low viewing numbers whether or not
those who numbers were like super high
or or not I don't know I that would be a
blind guess but I have to presume that
you know part of the recent fans were as
angry about is their worse because they
all watched it which you know is one of
the things that early on and these kinds
of cycles these studios can kind of
count on where you know if it's if it's
something that we don't have even if it
stinks at least initially we have a
tendency to flock to it if we it's
something we think we want even if it's
bad because it's all we've got
now that doesn't last you you you go too
long giving us just crap versions
eventually we stop giving a benefit that
we stop tuning in
but obviously Netflix wouldn't have hit
that period yet but let's let's just
talk about the general concept of doing
Cowboy Bebop specifically because
talking about doing anime stories as
live-action is it is a little bit of a
weird thing to talk about because they
actually do it a lot in Japan and I
don't know enough about the culture over
there to really kind of parse that
because the little bits I've seen of
those live-action movies is they just
seem really really weird because more
often than not they actually adapt
things that are specific to the anime
visual sensibility and do them anyway
even though it now makes no sense
because you're not in an exaggerated you
know art style you're dealing with real
people but they're still behaving the
way the animated characters it's weird
and I just have to assume cultural
difference on that but you know Netflix
is not doing this as a Japanese project
they're doing it as an American one so
like I said I'm not going
[ __ ] the broader idea of adapting animes
in general because like I said there's a
whole like thing going on with that that
I just don't know about it so Cowboy
Bebop specifically there have been
rumors of cowboy bebop getting some kind
of adaptation for a long time like when
the thing was first like Aryan getting
big over here and airing on Adult Swim
fair number of people were like throwing
out Keanu Reeves to play spike which I
mean you know half the time 15 years ago
okay yep
maybe now and we know but beyond that
there's a basic fundamental weird thing
about trying to do a live action version
of Cowboy Bebop whether you're doing it
as a movie or a series which I think is
why it stalled so many times up to this
point and actually I think extrapolates
out in general it's probably a big part
of why the live-action remake of Akira
has stalled as many times as it has
which is that one of the inherent
benefits of animation in general is that
you can do something you are not nearly
as confined by budget if you can draw it
you can have it you can have massive
robots huge space creatures insane
monsters transformations of people in
the demons all this stuff and it doesn't
cost you any more than it does to you
know just animate people walking down
the street well I mean it does cuz if
you want to do it well it's more firms
of animation us more time whatever but
my point is the the cost of doing
something visually extravagant is it's a
much less of a bump doing it in
animation versus trying to achieve that
in live-action so the thing about
something like Cowboy Bebop specifically
is Cowboy Bebop for how expensive it
would be to realize it accurately you
know all the space stuff the the pace of
it all of the locations the the visual
aesthetic that kind of stuff is not
cheap to realize in live-action to
realize visually convincingly because
you have to if you're doing it live
action otherwise what's the point it
like a cartoony yet but the thing about
Cowboy Bebop is it doesn't have a story
to scale up to that expense because the
general feeling that most studios
American studios at least tend to have
in approaching these things is the scope
of a story should should in some way
reflect the amount of money they're
spending it's why that you know they
spend way less money on small dramatic
films than they do on epic you know
comic books pace whatever's I mean
partly it's what can you get away with
spending but it's really hard to find
large-scale big-budget visually
extravagant films that also tells small
stories Hollywood doesn't really do that
as a rule because if they're gonna spend
that much money the feeling is we should
be telling an epic story we should be
telling a lord of the rings' level story
like the the best example I can think
that doesn't do that is something like
say Blade Runner both of them honestly
the first one a little bit more though
which is that it's a huge world massive
expansive it's a really small story
which is one of the things I love about
it is one of the reasons it's one of my
favorite films because I can't find that
in too many places when it comes to film
or just live-action in general an
animation you can do that so cowboy
bebop for all of the space adventure and
you know wacky weapons and all the stuff
go out it's really it's really small
stories it's just these bounty hunters
going after this one you know this
bounty that bounty sometimes they get it
sometimes they don't usually even if
they get it the payday is not what it
should have been uh and the few quota go
bigger things it does are really are
still really contained they're really
personal even if you want to try and
blow up something like say Spike's story
into something bigger it doesn't really
lend itself to that his story is first
of all for me and actually not one of
the better elements of the show but
is not grand and operatic it's still
relatively small and it's but it's
personal same thing if you're gonna dive
into jet or PHA not really so much edy
because we don't do a deep dive into ed
that would be weird but you know that
these stories aren't big but you would
have to spend a lot of money and I think
that's been the the general hiccup on
these I think that's why a live action
when we didn't have before I think it's
why when this was a previously proposed
as being a show over with Amazon they
never moved on it because I think
there's a disconnect between how these
studios view the amount of money it's
gonna cost them to spend versus what's
the story that's actually being told so
I think you're like there's one of a
couple ways this could go none of which
I'm particularly interested in I mean
I'd reserve the right to based off
trailer or first observer ever to be
turned around I'd like to be I like it
when my cynicism is proven wrong I don't
like having it confirmed but like to my
way of thinking there's a couple of ways
this could go either they they scale up
in accordance with what it would cost
them to realize this well in which case
they're basically just gonna turn cowboy
bebop into Star Wars which we don't need
or they're gonna trim the budget back
and we're gonna lose the sense of scope
that they're gonna do they're gonna
treat it like something like Firefly you
know hold on some Bottle episodes come
find to the ship single location stories
you know avoid the scope of it because
that's how you would contain the budget
and let's be honest netflix for as big
as they are they are not known for
extravagant spending like the one time
they notably spent a lot of money was
sense8 and they that was so expensive
for them that they basically had to be
bullied into doing the you know closing
out the story they wanted to just cancel
it so I I don't envision a situation
where Netflix Wow
I have a hard time believing they would
spend the money necessarily to necessary
to accurately recreate this story in
this world in these characters in the
first place
even if they if they do I don't know how
well they're gonna be able to resist the
studio gut instinct of being sure the
story is as massive as the budget and
then it just wouldn't be Cowboy Bebop
anymore I mean it's possible it's
possible that they find a way to give us
just enough that it looks right and it
looks convincing but they managed to not
spend so much that they feel the need to
mess with the story because I mean
ultimately that's always the thing the
more money gets spent the more the
people at the top tend to micromanage
that's why Warner Brothers is such a
mess right now because they decided a
lot of three four years ago or so that
they were basically gonna stop making
mid budget movies and we're only gonna
make huge blockbusters and then it's
studio interference right and left
because when you're spending 200 million
dollars on a movie you're gonna keep a
really close eye on it and then it just
you know it's become a mess so I mean
ultimately whether or not this has any
shot at being any good is gonna depend
on how much money they're willing to
throw at it but if they do trim the
budget back so much that they're willing
to let a director or writer or whatever
you know have the creative freedom that
they want is there gonna be enough money
to actually have it look like Cowboy
Bebop have it feel like Cowboy Bebop I
don't know I just I can't help but be
cynical about this and I might not have
talked about it except that you know I
am in the middle of revisiting Cowboy
Bebop for a podcast which I will I will
have a link to down below I put links up
for that in the community feed for this
channel so you can see those there too
but yeah it's the timing was funny as
far as that goes but I'll leave it off
at that cowboy bebop live-action Netflix
what do you think about this whatever
your thoughts are drop something down in
the comments let's talk about it there's
a whole bunch of stuff you can do
because there's buttons in there's links
including one to my patreon if you are
feeling generous if not don't worry
about it although you can check out
don't want to check those out that's
okay too because at the end of the day
folks you are the council I just run the
meetings and until next time this can
so is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]